[Musique]
la première question qui me vient à
l'esprit c'est de savoir si j'étais
intéressé l'astronomie très très jeune à
ce que tu étais de type de petite fille
à est avec son papa dans un parc ou dans
la cour regarder le ciel étoilé tri à
poser des questions sur les étoiles ce
que ça a commencé comme ça pour toi non
c'est un peu plate
j'aimerais ça avoir une histoire comme
ça raconte et d'un souvenir lointain
dans mon enfance où je me souviendrai
d'avoir toujours été passionné par les
étoiles par l'astronomie par l'étude des
astres mais malheureusement non je n'ai
pas noté le souvenir par contre quelque
chose que je me souviens très bien c'est
que j'ai toujours été quelqu'un
extrêmement curieux je me suis toujours
posé vraiment beaucoup de questions des
fois peut-être un petit peu trop au goût
de certaines maisons enseignants qui
étaient peu d'années que je bosse autant
de questions puis c'est ça qui m'a mené
est tranquillement à m'intéresser aux
sciences puis que fait que j'ai fait des
études en sciences au cégep
parce que je me disais peut-être que la
science pour moi en tout cas ça semblait
être la meilleure avenue pour répondre à
certaines des grandes questions que je
me posais à savoir d'où on vient
qu'est ce qu'on fait ici puis aussi
est-ce qu'on est seul dans l'univers et
ce qui est de la vie au delà de la terre
que ce ne sont pas les stars ne me moi
je suis vraiment un néophyte dans la
matière puis j'imagine que dans la salle
beaucoup de gens s'intéressent
connaissent notre système solaire mais
cette limite un peu peur est ce que tu
pourrais pour nous les humains les
dernières recherches
les dernières batailles de 25 années là
qui nous ont amené à cette découverte le
convoi par les 30 oh oui oui ça me fait
plaisir parce que dans les 25 dernières
années il s'en est passé des choses
donc c'est vraiment le fun pour moi de
parler de ce livre est de 5 années là si
on remonte il ya 25 ans 1992 support
où vous étiez mais en 1992 on
connaissait pas tant de planètes que ça
on connaissait les planètes de notre
système solaire mars vénus jupiter la
terre plutôt qu à tour et non la police
l'a arrêté des classes long de son
statut de planète donc on connaît ses
neuf planètes
puis au cours des 25 dernières années on
en a découvert beaucoup plus ça a
commencé en 1995
j'aimerais te dire que je m'en souviens
mais je m'en souviens pas non plus
j'étais en secondaire 1 quand même donc
acheté pas encore dans le domaine comme
tel mais c'est quand même assez récent
donc prendre un café vous souvenir ou
est ce que vous étiez en 1995 quand on a
détecté la première planète en dehors de
notre système solaire on appelle ça des
exoplanètes donc une planète qui tourne
autour d'une autre étoile que notre
soleil ça c'est en 1995 il y aura fallu
beaucoup de travail pour développer des
technologies développées des méthodes de
détection qui nous permettent de dire
avec certitude que oui il ya des
planètes autour de telle ou telle étoile
dans le ciel
ça a pris beaucoup de travail mais on y
est arrivé finalement 1995 quelque chose
qui vraiment aussi important dans
l'histoire des 25 dernières années c'est
la première dont la première mais là
l'envoi d'un satellite spatial qui
s'appelle le satellite spatial kepler
qui a été envoyé en 2009 puis lui aux
fêtes d'enfants a entraîné un véritable
bouleversement dans le domaine des
exoplanètes avant que kepler soient
envoyés dans 2008 2009
on connaissait quelques centaines
d'exoplanètes mais après son lancement
puis après qui a été fait observer les
étoiles pendant environ deux ou trois
ans maintenant faisons aujourd'hui on
connaît plus que 3500 planète 3500
exoplanètes donc ce qui est vraiment
extraordinaire en plus de dire que waouh
c'est même cool on connaît plein de
nouveaux mondes c'est de pouvoir faire
un peu d'abord une idée complète de
caisse qui a ailleurs dans l'univers
est ce que notre système solaire est
typique où est ce qui est plutôt unique
puisque on se rend compte jusqu'à
maintenant c'est qu'il ya certaines
particules
qu'il rende à c'est assez spécial mais
quelque chose qui est très intéressant à
propos du télescope spatial kepler c'est
qui a permis de déterminer que des
petites planètes comme la terre
c'était assez fréquent c'était assez
intéressant parce que les planètes qu'on
a découverte dans les premières années
c'était des planètes qui étaient des
grosses planètes des géantes gazeuses un
peu comme jupiter ou saturne dans notre
système solaire
c'est juste parce que c'est les plus
faciles à détecter en fait mais kepler
qui avait la capacité de voir les plus
petites s'est rendu compte que oui en
appui en a beaucoup
donc ça c'est vraiment inspirant quand
comme moi quand comme mes collègues on
est vraiment intéressé par découvrir non
seulement des exoplanètes les mieux les
analyses et mieux les comprendre mais
aussi peut-être trouver des endroits qui
sont habitables et qui auraient des
formes de vie qui possède la vie et là
on une belle découverte dont on a
entendu parler justement des exoplanètes
et tout ça est ce que tu peux nous
expliquer un petit peu plus qu'est ce
que c'est comme découverte puis en quoi
ça nous concerne nous les citoyens du
monde simple qui connaissent moins la
oui oui ça me fait un plaisir de vous
parler d'une découverte qui est annoncé
au mois de février cette année pour ceux
qui en auraient peut-être pas entendu
parler il s'agit de la détection de
cette petite planète autour d'une petite
étoile qui s'appelle trappistes 1 c'est
pas nous qui choisit les noms des doigts
les noms des exoplanètes malheureusement
donc les planètes autour de trafics on
s'appelle trappistes 1b trappistes 1,6
c'est vraiment plate mais ça marche bien
comme ça on s'est donné ce système le
donc ces petites planètes là qu'ils ont
à peu près la taille de la terre
ce qui est intéressant c'est que elle se
trouve dans une dans une région autour
de leur étoile qui est pas trop chaude
pas trop froide
donc elles sont elles reçoivent de leur
étoile qui beaucoup moins massives que
le soleil donc qui brille moins une
quantité d'énergie qui est à peu près la
même que celle qu'on reçoit du soleil
puisque et est intéressant j'avais
emmené cette diapositive l'eau pour que
la montre et c'est que étant donné que
les toiles dans le ciel
vraiment pas très brillantes mais pour
recevoir la même quantité d'énergie que
nous on reçoit sur terre du soleil de
cette étoile
il faut que les planètes soit beaucoup
plus proche de leur étoile
donc mon chapeau était il ya personne
qui a décidé ça c'est jusqu'à
s'attendent que ce système là est fait
comme ça m'est donc nono cette planète
si on se trouvait on parle à la magie
sur la surface d'une de ces planètes
voici ce qu'on pourrait peut-être voir
dans le ciel
tout ceci est une représentation
artistique je tiens à le dire on n'est
pas capable de se rendre là
malheureusement donc on serait capable
de voir notre étoile dans le ciel qui
malgré le fait qu'il est plus petit que
notre soleil est tellement proche de la
planète qui apparaît aussi grosses que
ça dans le ciel mais on serait aussi
capable de voir les autres planètes qui
apparaîtrait comme des croissants un peu
comme notre lune parce qu'elles sont
vraiment proches les unes des autres
on s'approche de science fiction pour
moi presque presque dans star trek
oui mais c'est vraiment intéressant de
voir ce mais encore une fois je dois
revenir sur le fait que c'est une
représentation artistique trappistes 1 1
c'est une étoile qui est située à 40
années-lumière
c'est dur de comprendre qu'est ce que ça
veut dire 40 années-lumière ça on n'a
pas vraiment bon je peux vous dire en
kilomètre 40 mille milliards de
kilomètres ça nous dit pas grand chose
quand même souvent me demande combien de
temps ça prendrait pour se rendre mais
la première chose à se dire c'est que si
on voulait envoyer un message là bas ça
lui on est là mais s'il ya quelqu'un ça
prendrait 40 ans à se rendre
si jamais il y avait quelqu'un il
pourrait dire qu'ils étaient vraiment
futé assez pour décoder notre façon de
parler bord pourrait dire oui je suis là
ça prendrait un autre 40 ans à revenir
les messages ont ont fait pas des
grosses discussions lors c'est pas du
texte live
mais si on voulait se rendre là bob et
tout ce que je peux dire c'est qu'on a
pas les moyens présentement n'est
peut-être dans l'avenir à la vitesse la
plus rapide descente jamais envoyé l'as
on your eyes and qui est présentement
dans le coin de pluton qui vient de
dépasser plus temps ça prendrait
plusieurs dizaines de milliers d'années
se rendre là donc ce qui est important
de comprendre pour le monsieur madame
tout le monde sait que je viens pas vous
parler d'un plan b
notre planète on part en voyage non
c'est pas une place pour déménager 8
milliards de tata non plus si jamais on
se tape notre planète
c'est vraiment chercher un accord qui
ont connu la référence à une émission
télé en vraiment génial et donc c'est
pas une place pour pour déménager
l'humanité mais ça reste quand même un
endroit très très très intéressant a
étudié avec des instruments qui s'en
viennent dans un futur très proche
ça doit développer à vitesse grand ça se
développe à vitesse grand v donc si je
vous montrais le nombre de détection des
exoplanètes par année là ça part très
très très doucement pendant les
dernières années là ça explose parce que
on a de plus en plus de technologies
d'instruments qui sont capables de faire
ces détections lopy un instrument que je
vais te parler en particulier si le
télescope spatial james webb
je serais intéressé à savoir qui a déjà
entendu parler du télescope spatial
james webb par applaudissements et il le
télescope spatial hubble qui a déjà
entendu parler
non contente pour certains d'entre vous
d'être la première à vous parler du
télescope spatial james webb compte dit
des fois le successeur de hubble qui va
aller dedans là dans la lignée du grand
télescope spatial hubble qui va
permettre de faire des tonnes de
découverte intéressante mais ce qui est
important pour nous c'est qu'un
instrument de l'agencé spatiale
canadienne sur ce télescope le
d'ailleurs le chercheur principal de ça
c'est rené doyon qui se trouve à
l'université de montréal donc la porte à
côté c'est mon collègue ici en fait
c'est mon patron donc on donc ça se
passe à montréal le développement que
cet instrument là qui fait
spécifiquement pour étudier l'atmosphère
de petites planètes comme celles qui se
trouvent autour de trappistes et se
télescopent le va être lancée en octobre
2018 et dès l'été 2010 neuf va commencer
à étudier l'atmosphère des planètes de
trappistes on l'a peut-être il y en a
parmi vous qui suis ok c'est l'fun
probablement que les chercheurs vont
être bonnes énervé de savoir la
composition de l'atmosphère des planètes
mais qu'est ce que ça change pour moi
oui c'est quoi notre futur gc ca qu'est
ce qui vous fait nous réserve tout ça
donc ce qui est intéressant à propos de
ça c'est clair
la vie telle qu'on la connaît les sa
trace dans l'atmosphère d'une planète
probablement qu'un exemple
malheureusement très actuelle c'est la
vie intelligente qui dégage beaucoup de
gaz carbonique dans l'atmosphère des gaz
à effet de serre ce qui fait que notre
la température de la planète
globalement augmente mais un exemple
beaucoup plus vieux c'est la l'oxygène
qui se trouvent dans l'atmosphère
l'oxygène ont été créés
presqu'entièrement par des organismes
fonda photosynthèse des plantes des
arbres
et puis s'ils étaient pas là cet oxygène
l'os on irait très rapidement parce que
c'est un gars qui réagit beaucoup
l'oxygène donc ça prendrait pas très
longtemps avant d'éliminer complètement
l'oxygène de l'atmosphère
donc bon il ya plein de détails que j'ai
parlé ici mais si on trouvait de
l'oxygène dans l'atmosphère d'une
planète par exemple celle de trappistes
1 par exemple avec ni reste l'instrument
canadiens à bord du pick up spatial
james webb
on aurait là une première évidence que
peut-être il y a de la vie sur cette
planète là évidemment ça restera à
confirmer mais ça c'est une première
évidence
et puis ça s'en vient dans un futur
proche je parle de vie ont pas au dessus
de quelque chose d'humanoïdes bon je
veux pas décevoir les amateurs de star
trek en toi ni d'autres amateurs qui
pourrait avoir dans la salle mais c'est
sûr que quand nous on parle de bain nous
quand les scientifiques en général parle
de vie extraterrestre c'est sûr qu'on a
l'impression qu'on aurait plus de chance
de trouver des formes de vie très simple
c'est des fonds de vie comme des
bactéries des êtres qui ont juste une
cellule qui s'adapte à une diversité de
milieux à une diversité de conditions
beaucoup plus grande que toi et moi
notre show où n'importe quel insecte par
exemple
donc on s'attend qu'il y plus de chances
que ce soit ce qu'on trouve mais comme
je disais les formes de vie plus évolué
j'essaie de dire en guillemets parce que
c'est peut-être pas particulièrement
brillant d'affecter la colère de son ca
planète mais laissent leurs traces aussi
dans l'atmosphère d'une planète dont il
pas exclut complètement qu'on puisse se
trouver autre chose grâce
cette technique là parce que tu pensé un
jour fallen découvrir aussi importante
qu'elle soit sur ton parcours comme ceux
aussi rapidement que je souligne que la
découverte des planètes de trappes et
enfin c'est pas moi qui a fait ça c'est
des chercheurs qui travaillent avec nous
mais c'est passé même pas des gens de
notre institut de recherche
j'ai eu la chance par contre de trouver
une planète pendant mon doctorat une
grosse boule de gosse était pas la
première place où on commencera à les
regarder de la vie mais c'était vraiment
une super surprise pour nous trouver
sympa ce qui est intéressant par rapport
au futur c'est que cette planète l'heure
contrairement à la plupart des
exoplanètes qu'on connaît elle n'a pas
été détectée indirectement à l'ap a été
détecté par les faits qu'elle a sur son
étoile mais elle a été vue directement
on est capable de voir sa lumière
pour l'instant on est juste capable de
voir des grosses boules de gaz comme
cette planète là mais dans un futur 10
ans 20 ans 30 ans on va avoir des
instruments au sol
on va avoir des instruments dans
l'espace qu'ils vont être capables de
plus en plus de prendre des images non
pas seulement deviner la présence d'une
planète mais de prendre des images
pas comme celle là mais un point de
lumière qui vient de la planète et ça ça
nous donne accès à une foule
d'informations que c'est notre meilleure
façon d'avoir une idée si de l'avis haut
niveau sur le plan peut-être personnel
comme chercheuse est ce que ça à voir
répondre à certaines questions pour toi
et pour nous tous parce que je dois 12
mois ses quais souvent on me demande est
ce que tu penses marie-eve toi qui
utilise un domaine ce que tu pense qu'il
ya de la vie ailleurs dans l'univers toi
qu'est ce que tu en penses
et puis bon mais je pense que ma réponse
est aussi bonne que la tienne donc la
vôtre après que je vous ai donné le
petit peu d'informations que je vous ai
donné le en 15 minutes mais moi je dois
dire que je tenais éternels sceptiques
donc j'attends de voir
j'attends de voir qu'est ce qui va se
passer mais ce qui m'inspire énormément
ce qui me passionne depuis ce qui fait
que je suis je suis épaté de pouvoir
évoluer dans ce domaine le jour après
jour c'est que dans dix vingt trente
j'ose pas donné de chiffres trop précis
mais dans les prochaines décennies
c'est nous le sait notre jeu
si on sait pas il ya cent ans et pas il
ya 200 ans et pas il ya mille ans c'est
nous on va avoir une première indication
à savoir si oui ou non il semble qu'au
mans pour les planètes qui se trouvent
dans notre voisinage solaire d'avoir une
atmosphère qui semblait réglé puis
probablement qu'on va être capable de
développer aussi des méthodes qui vont
incapable de nous dire sans équivoque si
oui sur cette planète là où il ya de la
vie donc 6 en or je pense qu'il ya des
bonnes chances qu'on soit capable de le
dire
ce postulat mais je pense qu'on va avoir
une bonne idée
est-ce qu'on a l'air d'être seul dans
notre coin d'univers dans notre coin de
galaxies ou est-ce qu'au contraire il
semble ça semble être achetés comme la
vie ailleurs dans l'univers qui d'une
manière ou d'une autre pour moi ça c'est
vraiment c'est troublant parce que ça
change rien ça change rien parce que ça
change rien dans notre quotidien on va
pas déménager là bientôt ou en tout cas
pas dans les prochaines centaines
d'années c'est pas ça le plein pour
vraiment préserver cette planète si mais
quand même ça ça change tout parce que
imaginez deux secondes qu on apprend
qu'il ya de la vie ailleurs qu'il ya de
la vie ailleurs sur une autre planète
comment se sentiraient s consentirait
pas un peu moins seul est ce qu'on s'en
serait pas un peu plus humble et ce
qu'on ne dirait pas au la terre et peu
spéciale on n'est pas au centre de
l'univers l'humanité est bon peut-être
spécial dans sa qualité d'être capable
d'être conscient de tout ce qui se passe
mais mes peu spécial parce qu'il ya
d'autres vies ça serait fou quand même
mais d'un autre côté si après tout nos
recherches on n'en trouve pas de signe
de vie ça veut pas dire qu'il y en a pas
il pourrait y en avoir à l'autre bout de
la galaxie puis on a aucune façon de
voir pour l'instant mais quand même je
pense que ça nous dirait quelque chose
sur la rareté de l'importance de
préserver ce conte et puisqu'on je te
fais donc en conclusion hâtive falloir
refaire nos olives pour nos
petits-enfants et ajouter des
exoplanètes dans une histoire c'est
celle de bonduelle et certains mais moi
personnellement mon fils je lui parle
déjà d'exoplanètes
comme mes parents ont pu faire avec moi
ça fait maintenant partie de sa réalité
ça fait partie de la réalité des jeunes
qui commencent l'université aujourd'hui
apprennent les exoplanètes comme moi
j'ai appris d'autre chose qui m'avait
été enseigné donc oui il faut il faut
réécrire l'histoire et c'est déjà
commencer puis j'espère j'ai bon espoir
que dans les cinquante ou cent
prochaines années
on leur écrivent avec un nouveau
chapitre qui porte le titre vie merci
mon dieu merci merci
[Applaudissements]